thought we'd play a round of jeopardy
and uh we're gonna do it
uh as close we're gonna honor the source
material as close as possible uh
chappelle will be your announcer chin
will be alex trebek and it'll be theo
versus brandon first cat so write your
names on the
on the board or on your uh thing and
then prop them up if you can
because they always those are your
buzzers
oh the name on this card no yeah yeah
name in the card
this julie fart huh this chewy fork yeah
chewie definitely just farted
it is chewy farting oh yeah i don't
trust that dog
wow i've said that from the jump i don't
trust them
yeah yeah it's pretty bad but it was a
it was a good filler
way too uh backwards so they can read it
right
and then if you get prop properly and
then they usually do like a little
doodle
um and uh we will begin
all right
this is jewelry
all right and we're going to take it to
our contestants
our first contestant coming all the way
from covington louisiana
owns his own clothing line called big
butts and mulluts
it's theovan everybody
[Music]
our second contestant coming from aurora
colorado
he is a kingpin of a biker gang that
only allows thick people
sargeant skinny's out there it's brendan
shove
[Music]
our last contact our last contestant
coming in from
san jose california she is working her
way
up to showing us those feet give it up
for cancer
everybody only fails
only feet holy feet and now chin you
say a little something intro of the show
guys welcome to the show
jeopardy begins now the first category
yeah read all the categories all right
we'll read all the categories out to you
they're schooling you in a group russian
history
flora vocabulary
and finally want to do and finally we
want to know who makes it
usually it's proctor gamble usually
uh you can uh tell them who goes first
we should have decided that those are
your buzzers wait till chin is done
reading the question before before
hitting the buzzer or else you will not
be called on
you we don't have a way to lock you out
unfortunately jeopardy does
that's how they that's how they police
that but you can block them on your
phone if you want them
good idea uh does someone have to pick
the how much first or
uh yeah you tom wu should go first and
pick the first category
cat can go first today is that okay i
don't know how to play but yeah go for
it cat which one you want
um i'm gonna go with
in a group for 200.
in a group for 200. seven years is a
song from this group
lucas is their lead singer oh [ __ ]
oh it's one of my favorite songs no it
is not
seven years old
all right we didn't get that one do i
tell the answer no yeah it'll go faster
okay the answer is lucas graham sorry
cat pick again
oh okay uh vocabulary for 200.
get again good luck vocabulary for 200.
word for the result you get when you
divide one number
by another why where's the where's the
question yeah where's it at
since alex left jeopardy sucks
maybe we should just use a ouija board
this is a
time so we like maybe we should just
play jenga
word for the result you get when you
divide one number by another
a dividend nope
is that it anyone else
[Music]
all right sorry the answer is quotient
or the question is quotient
cat pick again jesus what is quotient
correct correct thank you it's been a
while honor the man
chin what is quotient again uh
schooling you 200 school you
200. spanish
it's how you say river some are grande
grande
[Music]
river in spanish river in spanish i'm
going to go with what i press
top button top row top row
numbers yes brandon brennan guest i
didn't guess
yeah you did what happened you just
guessed out
but i didn't officially buzz in baby
let's get it all right next one pick
next
what is rio what is it rio oh
which one was that schooling you too
underscoring yeah it goes faster if you
just go
straight down the line once you pick a
category but i'm not going to be calling
you for 400 please
chen all right um so do i just read this
right
that's a little weird well alex had a
harder job than i thought he picked
he i think he had a smarter ticket yeah
that's fair
phys ed as patches said if you can do a
wrench
sorry if you can do it to a wrench fat
patches
you can do it to a ball so time to play
this game kids
dodgeball you got it you got one we did
it
[Music]
i'll take in a group 400. intergroup
400.
all right this is wrong too oh here we
go joe jonas joined
some friends in this band that served us
cake by the yoshi oh
[ __ ] oh what is dnce she got it
wow for four hundred i love jonas
brothers shout out to jack buttons
yeah someone helped deal with his butt
uh if you press the bottom row uh or not
not the bottom row the uh
uh top row the one with a oh there you
go that's the one
all right sweet another one with q
they're back sweet
go ahead cat come on cat uh let's do
russian history for 200. russian history
for 200.
it's usually hookers from 1917 to 1991
a federation of russia and other
communist republics
was known by this collective name theo
ussr please
what is i think uh we're gonna not wait
for him just because
that makes it too hard just first person
buzzing going forward ussr correct
okay leo give me that money good morning
give me that video's mom's like this
yes she's cheering you on dog
go ahead dog okay i'm gonna go with
vocabulary for 800
please
from the greek inscription it's a short
poem with a witty turn of thought
[Music]
what is an epigram
yeah yeah if whoever got it even if they
get it wrong okay yeah they just go
again vocabulary for one thousand for
theo i like how you guys picking the
real tough ones not doing the ones that
would be fun oh this is good
it's the correct name for a person who
eats fish but power their meats
pescetarian what he got it was stealing
oh i hit her nope i
hit it no yeah that that was nice oh
this is first
i think chappelle is the impartial judge
on this no
but first of all brenda's supposed to
have points because he got one right all
right
he got the uh dodgeball for four hundred
smooth
i'm going to go with pescatarian that's
correct
1 000. correct unbelievable you [ __ ]
me chappelle no i didn't
heard it first honesty wins always
brendan honestly
haven't you seen a lot of different
movies that are about that yeah
your pick doug yeah i will pick and i
want that g dawg thank you
who makes it for 400 please cheney who
makes it for 400.
the kindle paperwhite e-reader
who is amazon she got it correct wow
damn cat for 400.
who makes a kindle basically you're
losing brendan
well no i got a thousand but chappelle
cheated me out of it who makes it is the
easiest candidate
you're losing buddy go ahead kat uh
let's do
uh who makes it for 800. who makes it
for 800
galaxy tablets samsung correct brenden
for 800.
suck these nuts deal
[Laughter]
when did jeopardy become so intense who
makes it
who makes it 1 000. wow
you look like an acorn that got a job at
a feeding season
calm the [ __ ] down who makes it 1 000.
we're gonna we'll do in a second but
make sure to answer
in the question form good job what is
samsung
yep correct all right so who makes it
1000
crackle candy bars nestle
i'm sorry how do you say this what is
nestle
incorrect for 1 000. what is
hershey's correct yeah yeah
one thousand the mad nose candy
i thought nestle too give me some of
that candy police cat yeah that bratches
i want that branches i'll take who makes
it 600 chin
who makes it 600 for brendan shop thank
you
dog chow and catch out purina correct
damn
it correct what is purina her correct
for six hours who makes it 200. the
goddamn
oh sad you know what cats eat you sad
boy
you know what cats eat bruh you a
pervert though who makes it 200
you hooked bruh youtube dog
[Applause]
y'all loaded this thing up man and you
know what cats eat you
all right we're gonna take a break we're
gonna take our first commercial break
and come back and learn a little bit
about our contestants
[Laughter]
yeah i want alex back oh so this is when
i asked him yeah
pounding monster energy as well guys
alex would do that yeah he wouldn't do
that there's no bang at the gas station
that went to today
why should why is chin dressed up so
nice and nick mugging showed up
dressed up like a concierge at a lost
and found dude
[Laughter]
we haven't seen your blue shirt i don't
know what you're talking about you're
like security at goodwill
[Laughter]
yeah these bases are two for one okay
goodwill always has the weirdest [ __ ] in
this
in the one size 12 and one size 13.
but they always have those like those
glass cases with the weirdest the
weirdest [ __ ] it'll have like a swastika
in there
how much for that all right so uh
brennan's in the lead so let's
get to know brendan a little bit more uh
is there a story when you were younger
i wouldn't say a friend of yours was
having sex with a female and you tried
to intervene
to join as well can you tell us a little
bit about that story
this is
man you trying to get me kicked off the
show cause i'm dominating i see what the
[ __ ] is going on here this is jeopardy
brought to you by uh
what is it
[Laughter]
don't ask that kind of stuff disgusting
host
honor alex honor alec okay
brendan job you're there's an iconic
picture of you as a french robot can you
tell us a little bit more about that
story
how did that come to be when i was a kid
my mom made a costume of a robot
i had her drawn a mustache i looked
french i handed out the croissants
fascinating
i don't know the other story better
moving on
moving on cat uh what
it's my pick yeah you you ask a little
anecdote about olive oil oh
i hope that was good didn't lose their
virginity until college i don't think
right
no i lost my virginity when i was like
[Laughter]
14-15
apparently everyone wants to see your
feet is there a certain number
that would allow anyone to see your feet
uh yes
absolutely tell us that number yeah
throwing the number around
put it in my paypal how much i how about
three grand
three grand nah bro you gotta start a
little lower than that well that's how
much money i have
that's all you've got it started
uh 10 grand come on captain yeah just to
post a picture of your feet
10 grand is good 10 grand is pretty good
i think if it's one of those situations
where like
if it's in only fans where like you pay
for that like
pay-per-view thing yeah then sure why
not all right damn all right
all right chappelle lacey uh you love
white music
if you could be reborn would you be
reborn whoa
dude what is it senior citizen laughter
as well
why are we why are we also asking an
anecdote from the announcer i know right
i'm just saying
the [ __ ] fire
yeah who [ __ ] wrote these questions
that's why you work on this shitty show
instead of jeopardy dude
a white musician or yourself what would
you do
oh myself all the way all right
laughs like the hamburglar let's do it
no you got theo keep going yeah yeah
question
we know everything about them dude i
don't know do we
let's say candy corns huh these are good
okay
you're from new orleans yep um
when did you lose your lose your
virginity what
anywhere from 14 to 17. and it was
outdoors yeah it was outdoors
oh and they're throwing rocks at you but
it was near indoors right they were
throwing rocks at them
yeah very middle eastern are you still
afraid of rocks now
like hearing things break i've never
liked people throwing rocks at me
i also don't enjoy that some people
might be into it i'm not into it that
much should we do nick or no
enjoy people throwing racks no no do we
do a question with you as well uh no no
just the contest
i can't wait to see these jeopardy
[ __ ]
comment section it's probably like
firing the kid
we want alex back
well at least we are all together yeah
yeah brendan stern
i will take bring this 3 000 yeah
i will take i swept that category doug i
will take college educated
uh i will take in a group 600 in a group
600 for brendan
beyonce used to be that's me hitting
that
that's cat no that's me oh okay dusty's
child use the top
use the top row but yeah dusty's child
uh in the form of a question what is
destiny's child
got it correct for 600. and the party
is jumping jumping
brandon uh in a group eight hundred
and eight hundred justin timberlake used
to be in a group and sync and saying who
is it i hit it
i got it i got it no i did this one
first
okay well cat for who is that come on
man wow cat's doing good
she got it it gets so bad all right uh
let's do intergroup for a thousand for
songs like hall of fame and superheroes
stick to this band
danny oh donahue is in
who the hell is it
the answer is the script
i don't go ahead kat um let's do
schooling you for 800. schooling
big money okay big money daddy is that
there yet yep
all right english in the sentence
writing is difficult
writing is the six letter type of noun
sorry the correct answer is a gerund
a gerund a german a grunt
you're fired my god
okay let's do uh flora for six hundred
people are six hundred rhett arden
[Laughter]
here we go the wood of choice for
butcher blocks and bowling pins is this
tree whose leaves are seen
here what do you have the picture of the
leaf
what uh what let me see the answer
what is pine i'm gonna say what is uh
[Laughter]
the picture one threw me off it's all
right nobody gets that one nobody gets
that i don't think anyone's really
winning here
you know we're all losers yeah
flowers trees and [ __ ] like nature yeah
oh i thought it was a woman
okay all right do that for a thousand
then gotta miss alex
it's alec is it alex
it's alec isn't it is it
fahrenheit what what is fahrenheit
different
what is degrees
[Music]
this is awesome bro is this
i should first what it oh it's already
music take a break throw in your two
bits and name this music symbol
let's see the symbol
we gotta skip this one because i don't
have the [ __ ] all right
let's move to double jeopardy huh who
picked it
who picked it huh who picked double
jeopardy oh no no it's not daily double
we're we're on to the next round
oh i'm up reality tv shows 200. yeah
reality tv shows two hundred dollars uh
and and they don't exist yeah double
when you pick one just say double
because it's okay
reality tv shows double double for 400
okay
the the bravo channel has introduced us
to the real
who was it me the bravo channel
introduces to the real
housewives correct four hundred first
give me that bag son there you go theo
he's got some points
you're going hard now did you have a pen
pal off the real housewives yeah he
dated one
dated one i was trying to be cool man so
i said
it was all over it was all over the rags
i met one online
he said i made one online good for you
uh youth yeah my favorite
i used to work with them you did yeah
for bravo i wouldn't say you worked with
them did you uh
yeah they were on the show what about
vicki barbalak that's my
do i love vicky that's that dime maybe
that thicky thicky
yeah she was on the reality y'all got
housers on them too
vicky barbalac is she really i thought
she was a straight-up comedy so is
nae-nae
vicki barbalak no you're thinking of uh
nae nae leakes no
she does barbara likes a comedian oh she
is oh never mind i'm thinking about
vicky
yeah vicky what's her name facelift
vicky yeah vickie grundleson vickie
grumbleson yeah face vicky
yeah let's hear another one from let's
travel for
800. let's travel for 800. so this is a
double so that would be
a daily double he got a daily double
dude
bring that heat fam i'd like to wager it
all please
you can go up to 2000 since you don't
have it in daily uh since
you don't have that much yet i'd like
okay i'm going to wait your 600 please
all right visitors to this inventor's
new jersey lab can hear recordings from
his
1890 taking doll a costly failure
talking talking doll thank you very much
chappelle
jesus christ um i'm going to go
with benjamin franklin incorrect
fine he said fine
do you guys know no one else wanted
thomas edison
no no it can't jump in on a daily double
no oh gotta go
inside nothing now still feel i'm gonna
go with i'm like
on page one
[Laughter]
which i'm sure is what the listeners are
thinking during this game
i'm gonna go with four for 400 please
thank you guys
i don't feel like going into it says
holden caulfield
on page one of this book we're off to a
great start what is catcher in the rye
she got it correct for four hundred
dollars cat i can't believe you guys
were doing better when that dog farted
[Music]
um let's do
on my reading list for 800. on am i
reading this
check out the big brain on cats it's
actually 1600. here we go a cd of the
1777
oboe concert mozart what is mozart who
is mozart
correct oh wow
i'm gonna go with taking a new sat
for 800 for 1600 please alex 1600
to be labeled free of this type of fat a
food must contain less than
brandon right no okay okay uh
what is
it saturated nice incorrect for sixteen
hundred dollars oh that's the worst
all right uh i'll do reality tv shows
eight hundred
yeah sixteen hundred reality shows on
this cable channel have included bad dog
snake man and appalachian snake man of
appalachia
snake man of appalachia what is animal
planet correct
for sixteen hundred dollars cat she
needed it i did
i didn't eat it uh let's do
middle initials for 600. this empire
actress middle initial p
stands for panda swahili for love her
first name means hope
who is taraji p henson damn correct
for twelve hundred dollars god damn
culture all right time for final
jeopardy all right
all right
now we write it down on uh the piece of
paper right uh yes and your
and your wager um you so like you lose
you can wager zero you lose whatever you
wager so like
theo or you could put zero wage your
zero and still be ahead
this is more for cat so there's some
strategy
to how much you wager it's whoever ends
up at the end
with the most got it and currently
you have 3600 wager at all [ __ ] it
right yeah write it down don't spoil it
i'm glad i did not play this game
really yeah this is my first time ever
seeing a full game of jeopardy through
yeah jeopardy is pretty cool this is
exactly like it
it's uh it's just like this
i feel so smart when i get like three in
a row around my girl she's all day
i know that's right [ __ ] what's up
but then you always like but you then
you only get three for the whole night
it's [ __ ] tough you got a dvr the one
from the day before and then
just blow her mind all right
all right now is this the actual
question from the real jeopardy
yeah it was um i think you guys can get
it
all right be cool nick this practice
officially began in pakistan in 1977
44 years after an amendment ended in the
united states
this practice officially began in
pakistan in 1977
in the united states
this practice
[Music]
um
okay and then remember chin has to read
our answer
yeah yeah i feel like everybody's gonna
have the same answer
really does anyone go first or we just
go down the line
uh you pick with the lowest so go
through
all right theo you can take this
do we need to repeat this again the
question no i can't dude you haven't
seen this answer so theo is
is in third with 2200 and his answer was
chin you got to read it theo
what is public executions
for 1400 incorrect incorrect
y'all are haters dude for 3 600 what is
waterboarding incorrect how much did she
bet
all of it
for brennan's shop 200. these juicy nuts
also incorrect but i think brendan gets
it brandon
jeopardy what's the answer to that it is
a prohibition
goodwin oh oh pro chin say these
juicy nuts i said it i was hoping all
three of you would write smoke my natch
fam
i thought it was hanging man public
execution man that's not about you
oh you told us what was it prohibition
dude yeah because you have to
you can't just some people have to die
man yeah i hate to say that but it's
like you can't have everybody stay
around
uh how about when i was in phoenix you
know how they have all the biggest
comedians on the walls
to get your big ass up there all right
bill burke
crazy proud of you dog that's how they
do it thanks how they did it huh
they sent a and uh i put everybody's
favorite huh made the wall
i posted it baby yeah thank you guys
on your instagram it's you uh i read my
story
space a few days ago though michelle
wolf eliza
wow joe coy's up there joe coy kevin
hart
doug i sent you that you're you're the
only one who did this
i sent this thing goes oh it goes uh no
i didn't suppose
i sent a text it said why is this
playing i'm gonna send this to nick
theo's the only friend i have who
figured this [ __ ] out
oh i said cause i said take says uh dude
breaking news
pence uh it said trump stepping down
pence is gonna step in this is crazy
here it is i'm sent to you right now
nick
so it says the text says [ __ ] i put
shit's getting weird man
it looks like a straight link from a
news outlet says vp mike pence to be
sworn in
as acting president white house
officials say president trump to resign
at midnight tonight
click on the link source reuters via pbs
and then i sent it to the theory but not
click on it probably gay
but you click on it and it's the biggest
black dick you've ever seen in my life
why do you have to see it again well
you're the only one who got that right
the rest of my friends uh i got it right
no i said in the group chat and then you
got it no i said
i will not hit um i will not hit that
link because i know saw it
yeah i knew exactly what he was doing i
ain't down
oh but my but the reason i'm i was like
why am i telling the story oh
i sent it to joe coy he goes damn what i
go dude click on the link it's nuts read
it
and then he facetimed me he goes dude
what the [ __ ] man and show
oh oh that big ham everybody's seen that
guy i mean he passed away
he rested he passed away we already said
we talked about that a year ago yeah
is he back all of a sudden that was the
picture him again you didn't click on
you're smart
but joe coy goes dude i'm with my dad
he's facetiming shows he's dead
[Laughter]
he uh theo probably tried to click on it
but
phone wouldn't allow it yeah that's a
good point too yeah
i think steel would sound into it though
my dad came your dad came through i'm
looking
fresh bro everyone thought it was cedric
the entertainer i could
see that with the gucci shoes man
stevo came through